scene business family pick two you can
be a part of the scene you can be
successful in business can be great part
of your family but it's really really
really rough to do all three the most
difficult thing I've had now
particularly when I go through phases
where I'm super motivated and I want to
grow it's like the Friendship aspect and
the relationship aspect takes a hit if
you're trying to go full steam ahead
with your business I've noticed when
I've been in a relationship any spare
time that I have I have to devote that
to my partner which then means I have my
friends off whereas let's say for
example I was single then that gives me
an opportunity to spend more time with
my friends like to try juggle everything
is really difficult